5 25 on your Wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy how about an
electrifying viewer question about those
freeway HOV lanes
Antonio Wright please investigate the
use of HOV lanes by electric cars I got
a ticket for it in court a lawyer said a
law allowing it was passed but that the
details hadn't been worked out that was
six years ago
well the Nevada Department of
transportation's Justin Hopkins responds
ndot may have the ability to allow
electric vehicles to use HOV lanes
regardless of the number of passengers
but as of now there's no momentum toward
doing that
he adds that the idea is part of the
ongoing study of HOV lanes and Hopkins
stresses ndot's encouragement of
carpooling at the use of HIV Lanes to
save time money and Fuel and to lessen
carbon emissions and he adds while we're
committed to studying HOV lanes they
expect to maintain the two plus limit
occupancy for cars buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone and
join the driving a crazy conversation at
traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com